It always amazes me to see
how much disdain our culture has for young children.
It seems like everywhere I look on social media,
there are grumpy people complaining that children exist.
In restaurants, in Costco,
on airplanes.
Like, people are just so inconvenience
and so upset by families with young children.
It's crazy because we live in a society that is so old.
Like, our generation is not going to have
a lot of younger people around to take care of us
or just to be around us.
And so you would think that we would all recognize this
and we would recognize that, yeah,
those kids that are whining
and crying in grocery stores and causing a fuss,
like, they're loud,
but they are our future.
But no, instead
we just wish that they didn't exist
because they're just so inconvenient to us.
So instead we would rather just sit in silence
with our aging selves
doing nothing but consuming.
Like, I look at that
and I'm like,
like, my generation,
millennials,
I don't wanna grow old with you people.
You people are a tragedy and lame.
I always hear people say, like,
leave your kids at home
when you're gonna go into public.
Like, why don't you stay at home? Why don't.
Why do I have to be around you and your grumpy
sour attitude?
Like, that's way more annoying than a toddler crying.
It's honestly just so annoying.
So if you're a parent that has small Children,
please bring them out into public more,
please. Bring them to the grocery store,
to the restaurant,
on the flight to church, everywhere.
And if they cause a scene
and they make these grumpy people feel uncomfortable,
all the better.